let's try the four to three area code
caller from four to three okay I hear me
what's on your mind I can't man how's it
going
good how are you I'm doing great I just
wanted to call I'm from Tennessee and I
wanted to call about the midterm
elections and stuff good enough pretty
much yep
yeah um I don't know I'm kind of
concerned because honestly like I'm a
progressive I'm I'm more of a Democrat
than anything and I don't know it's just
kind of sad because in the 2016 election
I I was one of the people who voted for
Bernie Sanders and Hillary Clinton and I
just so like I didn't get any outreach
at all from Hillary Clinton or any of
the Democratic Party at all and I think
a lot of people are experiencing this
you know obviously we're you know all
the seats that the Democrats have lost
over the past decade I've obviously
shown that but at the same time it's
like we have great candidates I mean in
Tennessee for governor we have Karl Dean
and he's the former mayor of Nashville
and he was awesome and then we have a we
have a young like veteran who's very
progressive running for the Senate he's
the only one who's even running right
now for the Democratic Party he's not
even like supported by the Democratic
Party at all but I feel like he's a very
Tennessean person and I don't know I I
just feel like he could actually win
they're running against Marsha Blackburn
and Diane and black yeah so it's not
like very likable people that they're
running against so I don't know I just
wanted to get your opinion on yeah I
mean you know there's a couple different
things going on here number one I mean
the reason that you weren't reached out
to by the Hillary Clinton campaign quite
frankly is because the Democratic Party
conceded Tennessee from the get-go right
so it was really just the writer of we
have a system that's an electoral vote
system there was no way that Hillary
Clinton was going to win Tennessee so
any dollar spent on you we're going to
be dollars basically wasted and it's not
about Hillary Clinton or Bernie or you
as an individual it's just the system
that we sort of have and and that's
going to take much broader systemic
change than anything about the
particular candidates whether it's
Bernie or Hillary you know what I mean
yeah I know I understand that completely
and I get that you know they got a win
electoral II but at the same time I mean
you gotta at least compete in the States
because I
feel like a lot of people at least in
Tennessee are pretty liberal but they're
just not like politically active I guess
yeah like I would say millions of people
in Tennessee are not politically active
and they're not necessarily conservative
people like they're more moderate than
anything I mean most of the political
offices or people that we have been
political office now are fairly moderate
can considering you know a lot of other
states in the south and I don't know I
just feel like if the Democrats actually
competed and actually tried I mean only
20 years ago Bill Clinton was sweeping
Tennessee so I just feel like we could
do something differently and yes that
part of as a Democrat completely on
board and one of the problems that I'm
working on a story about how to fix the
Democratic Party speaking as someone who
is not a Democrat myself but is
progressive and one of the areas is the
the local level game the state
legislatures state senators mayorships
of big cities even paying more attention
to governorships in some purple or red
states it's all got to be fixed because
the infrastructure you know it's very
easy to say Oh Republicans are using
voter ID and other voter suppression
tactics to win it's way more difficult
for them to do that if Democrats were in
more control of cities election
commission's state houses state Senate
seats etc so I mean I could not possibly
disagree with what you're saying you're
absolutely spot-on and I just am not
convinced that under Democrats Inc and
Tom Perez's leadership there's really
going to be major strides made there oh
I'm with you completely I was pretty
disappointed when Tom Perez was elected
over keith ellison but yeah i you know
it's it's one of those things that's
going to take time and i think that i'm
hoping at this point that the democratic
party has learned it's lesson but it's
kind of obvious that they really haven't
yeah
you know a lot of them are getting older
and i think it's you know going to be
another election cycle or so and I'm
just hoping that whoever is the 2020
candidate you know can get enough
support across the board and people can
actually realize that they need to vote
but you know I think but by the way I'm
a huge fan of your show man keep doing
what you're doing you're awesome and
yeah you know people in Tennessee and
all over are listening to you man
alright appreciate the call thanks very
much great
here from Tennessee not affiliate we
often hear from